投資朋友歡迎收聽早晨財經速解讀。現在是臺北時間2026年10月6號禮拜二,早上8點31分。大家早安,我是丁浩。
每天早上開拍前半小時,我們在這邊陪伴著各位一起解讀國際財經新聞時事變化。
那儘管美國國債殖利率還在走高,
但是市場投資人現在還是把目光主要集中在這一次比較強勁的科技基本面和經濟上的數據。
10年期美債值率昨天已經來到5.31%了
30年期已經來到5.66%了
這兩者都還是處於極端高位
所以美國股市到目前為止
納指昨天又創下歷史新高價
臺股也創下歷史新高價
那隨著內部的輪動越來越劇烈以後
我們到底要如何來看待這一次
臺股衝上5萬點之後
它會不會只是另外一個起始點呢
至少就目前來看
美國股市最大矛盾
其實還是在歷史新高附近
可是底下大量股票
其實部分股票已經進入到熊市了
這是比較大的壓力
從6月份以來
我們從羅素2000
或者到羅素3000成分股
大概有51%的股票
至少已經下跌超過兩成了
半導體更誇張
高達96%的股票
曾經回測20%以上
69%的跌幅超過40%
那我們應該講說
總體來看
軟體股大概有75%左右的部位
進入了20%以上的回調
汽車股有71%
所以必須承認
這一波的上漲
體感上
其實就連臺股也是蠻明顯的
也不代表說
任何的投資人都有那種
明顯活在牛市上的氛圍
畢竟現在主要還是藉由高價股
和大型科技股來向上進行拉抬
標普500中位數股票
距離52周的高點
目前大概也是下跌了接近16%左右
但指數之所以還是撐得住
就是因為企業獲利在大型企業當中
還是有比較明顯的支撐
所以現在重點就來自於
要如何修復現在的債券波動率問題
我們從MOOF指數來看
現在已經突破100了
但VIC指數還在15上下做附近震盪
所以如果接下來MOOF
債券的恐慌指數很快的下滑
那可能市場的廣度就會追上指數
那股市就繼續上漲了
那你如果說60% 70%的股票都還在繼續下跌
但是呢
美國股市就目前情況來看
還藉由這些大型科技股往上拉抬
那總有一方可能走錯了方向
這個時候市場壓力就很大了
持利率其實也不太有利於股市
所以這一步我們必須承認
能源價格的上漲
對於股市和經濟上的威脅
的確已經步入過去幾次的油價衝擊這麼大了
途中我們看到的黃色線是布蘭特雲油的年增幅
藍色線是標普500企業獲利的年增幅
可以看到從89年到91年
07年到09年
當時雲油價格波動劇烈的時候
企業獲利都會快速的惡化
甚至變成衰退
但目前情況不一樣
你看油價漲成這樣這麼離譜
柴油價格也創下歷史新高了
結果標普500的獲利增速
反而持續的拉抬
現在是接近30%
換句話說
原油價格上漲
它確實會增加通膨和成本的壓力
而且把殖利率整個給拉高了
可是隻要企業的獲利和景氣
要能夠足夠的動能強勁
現在看起來
經濟吸收能源衝擊的能力
比衰退前夕還來的表現更好
當然部分股票吸收的並不好了
所以現在的重點就來自於
到底過去突破了4.5%
線殖利率的分水嶺之後
市場上會如何來反映
標普500的預估的遠期
前瞻本益比
因為現在從當時4.3
今年5月份才4.3
然後到4.4
4.5
4.6
4.7
現在突破5%了
標普500的預估本益比
也從21倍一路壓回到19倍左右
這就是一個新的格局
其實如果從標普等權指數來做觀察
大家就可以觀察出跡象了
這張圖表是標普等權指數
就是他不是用加權來做進行統整
他是把每一支企業都設定為五百分之一
那標普有五百家企業嘛
如果呢
每家企業均等給他設定一定程度的資金投入量
那到現在為止
才剛剛碰到半年線左右
其實位階是很低的
跟道瓊差不多
已經跌到差不多今年五月六月左右的水準了
所以從標普等權指數來看
整個標普漲幅就不是特別的漂亮
漲幅就不是特別的誇張
而且甚至還在做比較大的中期回調
那背後就是AI的集中度
我們如果把AI股票剔除在標普白指數之外
現在大概相對於8月底的高點是下跌接近有7%
等於把整個夏季度的漲幅都已經剔除了
或者說回吐了
那AI全職股現在就是把大盤撐在高位的主要原因
本季度光是對於獲利成長貢獻最大的10家公司
大概就包辦了標普500超過三分之二的整體獲利成長
所以資金就全部灌到這些大型科技股當中
那這就是股票市場的K型分化
就不是講說一般民眾的體感
而是股票市場當中內部的K型分化
它導致了很多人付出更高的避險成本
如果我們排除AI的相關大型股
標普500的下跌的保護明顯更貴
明年三月份到期
預約價大概為限價85%左右的賣權
標普500的避險成本
大概是101個基點左右
但如果你把排除AI之後
就會升到132個基點
所以整體而言都看得出來
AI巨頭它不只是撐住指數的報酬
它整體來看也壓低了
整體標普500指數看起來的下行風險
那你一旦把這些AI大型科技巨頭給拿掉
其他美國股市的公司
它的風險定價就明顯更高了
這就是真實情況
所以你說難道市場沒有避險嗎
市場不恐慌嗎
不看大型科技股大家就恐慌了
但是把大型科技股一加進來
看到它的獲利
大家就沒這麼緊張了
那這也形成另外一層效果
那就是能不能借由大型科技股撐住指數
然後藉由利率市場的寬鬆
或者利率一起的下滑
把小型股給救回來呢
這又有難度了
為什麼呢
因為最近美國服務業公佈的偏挨數據
又遠遠高於預期
如果昨天我們所提到的
非農低於預期
非農的暴冷
對於股票市場是利多
因為利率預期下滑
那麼現在服務業
衝出五年最強的表現
經濟越強
那不是反而變成
殖利率上的利空了嗎
所以必須承認
現在從標普全球服務業偏愛來看
已經來到58.8
這比8月份的56.5還要來得高
而且是五年來的新高
那這種高強度的經濟服務業的表現
美國第三季的經濟成長速度
可能會重新回到4%以上的增速
光是從9月份來看
可能就已經來到5%了
這種高速的擴張
其實你也很難去預料
殖利率有快速下滑的可能性
這就是美國股市現在面臨的處境
簡單來講就是
其實內部正在分化
也不是股票市場沒有出現恐慌
但恐慌都是小股票
所以指數上看不出來
那真實體感上的大恐慌
都是集中在美債波動率的move指數
你看從9月10號大概77左右
現在已經飆到113了
這個幾乎回到3月份市場恐慌的最高點了
但你看VIC指數在完全完全不波動的
資金完全從股票市場來看是看不出來的
除非你把它給細分化
這就沒有股市現在的概況
那你說那如果原油價格能夠回跌
是不是有利呢
原油價格大概卡在100美元左右
不過現在真正的問題還是供給仍然不夠了
整體來說
荷姆茨海峽和替代管線出口的原油和成品油
平均每天大概在1700萬桶
其實已經慢慢在走高了
可是問題在於相對之下
相對於戰前仍然不到十分之一
第二大問題
現在其實往下游端傳導是川普最為注重的
就是柴油和戰爭風險的持續加劇
俄羅斯現在是限制了成品油的出口
加上波斯灣供應不足
所以使得現在市場柴油的批發價
每桶大概是200美元
美國現在柴油零售價格
大家稍微也看到了
美加侖大概就是6塊
6.5塊起跳
川普最近又準備要開始限制美國柴油的出口
那歐洲可能就要被迫搶購更多地區的原油
所以導致布蘭特原油
已經比西德州原油高出了12美元
所以從這樣的一個角度來看
短期內
如果期中選舉之前
川普也不採取更進一步的軍事動作
那可能就會僵持在這樣的一個區間
從汽油價格來看
現在美加侖大概在10月初是4.4美元每桶
這個數據雖然沒有說完全突破
當時在2022年的6月份高點5美元
可是它也比2022年當時的10月份來的貴了
也比2023年10月份來的貴
也比2024年比2025年的10月份都還來的貴
所以現在的通膨壓力情況
幾乎媲美於拜登在2022年的烏二戰是差不多的水準
OPEC在11月份目前所採取的新態度也是不增產
真正的問題就是有配額他也增不出來了
即便給你多增產幾個配額
基本上能夠順到市場上的原油也是非常有限的
這就是目前原油供給受限的影響
川普在幾個小時之前也發文表達態度了
他說現在造成汽油價格上漲的原因
已經不是荷姆治海峽
他在社交媒體上寫
目前幾乎每天
其實都有大量的原油運出
數量甚至率創新高
他認為現在真正的問題
是煉油廠
川普表示
俄羅斯的煉油廠
正在遭到烏克蘭的轟炸
而美國自己的煉油廠
也有在加州
這一類民主黨主政的州
陸續關閉
這都是那些蠢蛋
民主黨人害的
這是他的貼文
雨斃
鬨堂大笑
好 那不管怎麼說
這就是川普目前的態度
看一下它短期內也無法解決
但是代表著利率有可能會維持在這樣的一個區間
維持得更久
那目前10年期美債殖利率
因為已經比標普過去12個月的盈餘殖利率還來得高了
跟股息殖利率的差距大概也擴大到4個百分點
兩者都是2000年初以來的最大
那美銀現在就把利率分成五六七三個階段
4.5的時代已經過去了
5%以上投資人可能會開始覺得
那股票跟債券好像都可以買哦
那到6%以上
通常殖利率的上升
就會開始壓低股價的報酬
7%以上
估值本益比的壓縮
就會全面的展現
那歷史上
10年期美債殖利率處於5%到6%
而且又在陸續上升的過程當中
其實標普是有機會能夠繼續上漲的
升到6%到7%以後
按照過往經驗
平均報酬就幾乎為0了
短期內升到7%以上
通常就要進入到負報酬了
所以美銀的看法是
5%也不是股市的死亡線
只要企業獲利還在持續
大家就同時高利率跟高獲利成長並行
那到6%到7%以後
雖然股價不一定會中跌
可是本益比大概也已經崩掉了
那目前標普擺的本益比
大概是20.4倍
整體來說
其實已經相對於過去幾個月下滑算蠻多了
這就是第一層我們觀察到的實質跡象
就是大家想了想
算了5%殖利率也沒有說到這麼痛
等到6%7%再說
會不會6%7%以後再往後延後
以後AI大爆發
一年報酬低於10%的債券
大家都不買了
搞不好
所以這就是一個新時代
我們開始習慣高利率時代的展現
那看一下美國股市的表現
一樣繼續反映大型科技股向上衝
道瓊上漲90點0.18%
說在51267點
標普上漲51.0.66%
說在7773點
納指上漲286.1.05%
刷27477點
創下歷史新高價了
非班上漲36.0.28%
刷13172點
觀察幾隻個股
SpaceX在昨天股價漲了8%
馬斯克現在他的身價視角
重返到兆元富豪的寶座
那當然了
主要還是來自於市場上
在短期內針對新建的是非
還有對於AI業務的成長動能
有進一步的拉抬
他也這樣子默默站回來了
那個時候IPO價格
也是一路的重挫
然後花了一兩個月的時間
慢慢拉回來
那美國科技圈
現在也針對AI的名稱之爭
開始做比較進一步的一個變化
我們都很清楚知道
因為川普最近
開始推的是SI
要取代AI
所以馬斯克也預估
未來會把SpaceX AI的名稱
改成SpaceX SI
所以簡稱SpaceXSite
差不多是這樣子
但這個改名還在一個宣佈階段
馬斯克也沒有確切公佈的時程
會不會到時候連代號也要改
那不重要
重點來自於
因為最近是馬斯克的談話
所導致臺積電ADR的直接破高
這一次昨天臺積電ADR又上漲了2.75%
國家創下歷史新高
主要就是馬斯克TerraFab
最近早上的臺積電
可能變成臺積電蓋廠
SpaceX出錢然後包產能
雖然現在目前表示還在討論階段
不過讓大家意識到臺積電的訂單業務越來越廣
目前可能傳出的架構是由臺積電出面興建
持有並且運營一座晶圓廠
專門服務特斯拉SpaceX還有XAI
SpaceX會投入建廠的資金
承諾長期的採購產能
甚至兩者同步進行
像臺積電因為擁有全球最大規模先進製程的能力
所以作為TerraFab的合作伙伴
其實相當合理
那之前我們也知道
馬斯克本來就有龐大的晶片需求
要自己做
你說跟Intel
因為Intel四月份就已經加入了
那會不會雙方分工
來承接不同的製程
和不同晶片模式
那我相信時間久了以後
馬斯克最後一定會希望
把更多的訂單給臺積電
因為良率比較高
這是值得觀察的效果
這也直接帶動了臺積電的走高以後
搭配著低軌衛星PCB的狂歡
昨天臺積電臺股市收漲1236點
現在準備要扣關5萬點了
成交量也放大到1.15兆了
這種金金漲的行情
就是本來臺積電都這樣
都盤整很長一段時間
然後突然就拉動了
盤整很長一段時間就拉動了
臺灣的高價股權支股都差不多了
這很少一漲
從年初漲到年尾的
通常都
你看臺積電以前五六百塊也是
一給你盤
一給你盤一年
然後兩個月就給你
可能漲了30%
40%
臺股也是這樣子一路走過來的
我們以前開玩笑
看空的後悔
後悔沒買的
就是看空的後悔
做空的也後悔沒有買
買的也後悔沒有買夠
然後all in的又後悔
沒有去信貸all in
就你總會覺得說
這個臺股的報酬
好像提早應該做一些參與
應該說做一些準備
但是總是後悔
應該當初多買一點的
每個人都在後悔
但臺股其實我們都很清楚
這幾年就是這樣子
一路斤斤漲漲上來的
那對於現在臺股的顯著拉動
我們要如何把它來看待
當前市場籌碼的變化呢
我認為最為直觀的
其實就是外資開始迴歸了
對喝多了
沒有喝多
啤酒節已經結束了
OK
那創高之後
到底這一波是由誰來做拉動的
我覺得昨天就很有趣了
投信昨天賣了63億
但是外資買了718億
那到底有沒有可能在外資的回補底下
終於迎來新一波的顯著拉昇呢
因為其實過去幾個季度
我們都看得出來
都是靠投信
都是靠內資
有比較顯著的買盤做支撐
那硬是把臺股撐在這樣的位置
那外資其實賣壓
有時候三月份或者七月份很大
如果外資能夠藉由這一輪開始做迴歸
那臺股就有可能幾乎到幾盆了
基本上是這樣子
如果臺股股市是外資還是偏賣方
那臺股就慢慢的創新高
那外資偏買方
那就算投信不滿
那就是快速的創新高
這是目前的看法
所以風水輪流轉
上半年我們清楚知道
還是由韓國股市獨領風騷
時間線來到下半年
臺股股市現在以67%的漲幅
現在已經排行第一名了
南韓綜合指數
COSPI指數上漲65%
位居第二
日經225是上漲37%
那相對之下
美國標普白指數上漲12%
加拿大股票市場上漲10.9%
富士指數只上漲5%
亞洲內部也不是全面上漲
我們看上證指數反而下跌3.2
恒生指數下跌4%
法國CAC指數
最近也是下跌3.9%
越跌越重
印度50指數更是重挫了14%
所以今年並不是亞洲勝過歐美
是臺灣南韓日本
只要是科技半導體權重比較高的市場
就是大幅度的領先
如果我們細看
你看法國股市
最近是慘不能躲
一個慘字
歐洲股市最近就很明顯分化
法國股市
如果我們從高點這樣子跌下來
其實它已經跌到差不多
三到四月份
當時每一戰事的低點了
那很明顯
就來自於歐洲市場
一方面在AI的追趕是有限的
另外一方面
法國內部
不管是最近學藝的問題
還是在財政刺激的情況
其實都有陸續展現
歐元市場也是如此
歐元現在大概已經跌到
17個月來的低點
這個很明顯
一定有反映一些政治風險
或者法國財政危機升溫的問題
現在10年起
法國公債和德國公債的利差
已經擴大到152個基點了
這是2011年歐債危機以來
第一次見到
現在法國 意大利 比利時
比較高債務的這些國家
也開始重新受到市場檢視
這就是觀察到全球市場
你說今年是一個大牛嗎
就看你是哪一股人
法國人你覺得今年很慘
對於臺灣股市
臺灣股民
韓國股民而言
今年真的是躺著賺
因為現在就是靠基本面的獲利做支撐
現在臺灣半導體
今年的獲利年增幅
大概是成長40%到50%左右
韓國市場在低潤記憶體價格
目前來看
現貨價格還是明顯高於合約價
我們看DDR5
16GB的現貨價格
9月份一個月又漲了7%
目前相對於9月份合約價
仍然有20%左右的溢價
DDR4 8GB供需更加吃緊
9月份現貨價格又漲了5%
相對於9月份合約價的溢價
已經高達40%了
所以不管是DDR4 DDR5
在25年我們都知道
它價格都還算是平穩階段
從整個下半年開始往上攻
到26年到現在10月份
價格居然還沒有任何停下來的跡象
這也導致了美國半導體的銷售額年增幅
本來以前都是20到30%
現在在2026年年初達到60%
現在10月份已經來到120%了
就是以這種速度持續的往上來做暴升
整個東亞製造投入價格也全面的升高
任何PPI價格都在做快速的顯著拉昇
加上臺積電最近也在評估德州市首
要再蓋一個大型的軍營廠
那單做至少會200億美元
AI需求的全球產能
看起來會持續的擴張
這就是一個新時代的一個借鏡
這當然會形成一種
內部的資金排擠效果
我們如果細看
最近在今年前7月
最近所公佈的
臺灣銀行新增的放款
已經高達4兆臺幣了
大概是1260億美元
光是整個7月份
單月份就增強了1.04兆
這是歷史的新紀錄
主要是契金
銷金
新增的貸款都同步創下新高
所以從這樣的一個角度來看
代表的是
臺灣雖然油資是很充沛的
可是現在市場有信心的
借錢的速度
快要去追上
錢流進來的速度了
過去企業貸款的審核
大概是要三個月左右
越來越多科技公司
要求銀行在兩個月內
完全它的核貸
也反映現在市場在搶產能
要搶資金的速度
正在快速的拉抬
最明顯出現的數據是在週轉金
如果我們看7月份
當時企業和個人用於週轉金需求的銀行貸款
單月是增長8200億
增量大概是購物貸款的接近有8倍左右
相對之下
房屋市場就很和緩
整個8月份房貸餘額大概11.9兆
年增幅只有4.6%
反而現在都是集中在企業貸款
或者在信用貸款層面
資金爆發之後
第一個結果就是錢變很貴
從整個金融市場的流動性指標來看
企業貸款利率
現在大概已經上升0.9個百分點了
房貸利率從25年最低是2.2
現在平均已經來到3%
這也說明著
雖然臺灣銀行是沒有升息
不過銀行看起來自己已經先升息了
這不能說臺灣銀行有資金荒的問題
只能說現在借錢的需求
快要追上錢流進來的速度了
所以油資是不是充沛
油資是很充沛的
買股市的錢是不是很多
是很多
可是現在更多人想借錢買股票了
這就是提前的一個投資效果
最終導致的結局就是
不只是電子業
現在的獲利爆發
臺灣金融業的獲利
也正式爆發了
最近看到銀行保險
證券投信
三大金融業的前八個月
稅前盈餘
已經來到一兆一千七百零二億
比去年同期
暴增了94%
你要知道
臺灣今年的整體大盤
大概EPS年增幅大概40%
那部分個股可能是70到80%
銀行業是賺一倍
光是八個月就已經超過
2024年一兆588億的歷史記錄了
這就是我們觀察到
現在金融業也處於極端的爆發期
這就是歷史新高
當然多頭回過頭看好像理所當然
可是投資真正困難的地方
從來都不是事後知道
臺股長期最後會創高
是你能不能撐到
創新高的那一天
這跟戰爭的道理很像
我們最常看出的
未必是方向
是時間
我們當然知道
AI會提高生產力
我們知道企業的預估
獲利總有一天會成長
股市總有一天會創新高
可是你原本以為
可能是下個月就發生
想不到等了半年
想不到等了三年
想不到等了五年
結果中間又碰上
30% 40%的回漲
結果可能就完全不同
槓桿的人他可能被迫先斷頭
7月份女的被斷頭的那些人
他不看好AI嗎
他一樣看好AI了
但他看對了趨勢
他最後死在了波動
所以有時候我們要這樣想
市場最後能夠創新高
跟你有沒有留在市場等到那一天
其實是兩回事
你要有心理時間性的預估
你能夠留在市場多久
你要想想看
我最近才看到一篇報道
那個普丁是2022年2月份入侵烏克蘭
這場戰爭已經打五年了
已經超過一次世界大戰的時間了
那你要想想看
如果他在入侵烏克蘭的那一天
他知道打五年還沒辦法結束這場戰爭
他還會發動戰爭嗎
1937年
當時日本的決策者知道
對中國開戰不是幾個月就能夠結束
他要一路打八年
那你覺得還要打太平洋戰爭
他們還會做出同樣的抉擇嗎
又不是像電視劇裡面演的一樣
同志們
我們八年抗戰已經達到第七年
他沒辦法提前知道會達到八年
所以同樣的
03年美國的決策者知道
推翻海山政權
可能只需要幾個星期
結果需要八年的駐軍
他還會打下去嗎
每個人都相信戰爭不會打這麼久
但真正被低估的
有時候是時間
所以其實在股市投資也是一樣
你能夠熬到最後
時間就是你的
投資上的形式就是我們最常看錯的
有時候都不是AI看錯了
方向看錯了
都是時間看錯了
不要被市場給洗掉
這是很重要的
你要多問一句
如果我要再多等三年
那我撐不撐得起自己對的那一天
這兩天我才去看皇家啤酒屋
1920年希特勒就在那邊
發表了納粹黨的25點綱領
然後德國工人黨這個時候也改名稱
國家社會主義德國工人黨
你今天走進去
也許都是樂隊
都是觀光客
100年前
這件事情最值得反思的地方就是
大家都在談這個聚會口號
然後一個民主社會的危機開始爆發
那我就在想
我想說如果1920年
如果希特勒他就站在那邊
他知道25年以後的結局
他原本想要追求千年的帝國
只會存在短短幾十年
德國城市最後化為灰燼
納粹犯下的大規模屠殺
種族滅絕
那最後自己只能躲在碉堡裡面
然後最後選擇上路
所以歷史上最令人感慨的地方
就在這邊
有時候我們不知道
真正這條路能夠通往哪裡
但如果你先知道結局了
那你撐得到最後嗎
一樣你知道結局是很悲慘的
你還會下那個判斷嗎
這個是很重要的
值得觀察的重點
好那不管怎麼說
現在我們看到股票市場
處於不叫極端的分化
大型股跟小型股的分化
那股票市場跟債券市場的分化
那各國股市有AI和沒AI的分化
那最後所形成的一個效果
當然是這場遊戲
能不能持續玩下去
那現在能夠玩下去的幾個原因
除了我們剛才看到的基本面推升以外
它背後其實還是來自於創造流動性
就是有更多的錢
我們看AI基礎建設
現在已經開始進入到一個新的階段
科技巨頭不再只是自己拿現金
蓋資料中心買晶片
越來越多公司運用SPV
特殊目的公司
來把AI投資移到資產負債表之外
來獲取更多的資金
而且同時讓資產負債表
表達相對亮麗的表現
我們根據相關統計
現在大型雲端業者
加上輝達博通的表外承諾
大概已經從1.8兆
在短短一個季度
現在10月份已經來到3.1兆了
暴增了1.3兆
我們來探討兩個案例
一個是亞馬遜
另外一個是博通
亞馬遜是最近把80億美元
揮打的Blackwell晶片
移入到特殊目的公司
那這些晶片呢
已經部署在美國五個州
超過12座的資料中心裡頭
SPV透過舉在向亞馬遜買下晶片
再把同一批的晶片
長期租回給亞馬遜
那外部投資人最多可以
持有SPV公司大概10%左右的股權
亞馬遜可能是完全不持股的
這樣做的效果是什麼
就亞馬遜可以繼續使用這些晶片
那是原本直接放在資產負債表上
數十億美元的資產和相關融資需求
它就移到了外部的投資工具
那背後原因很簡單
就是AI投資的支出實在太龐大了
亞馬遜2026年的資本支出
預估是2200億美元
大部分投入到亞馬遜雲端業務的
晶片和資料中心
現在整體來看
3月份它已經發行了370億
到現在要發到500億
然後到7月又發了250億
越來越發越來越弱
它當然資產負債表
表現就越來越不好看
那就用其他方式來獲得資金
那就藉由不斷的向外擴張
把保險業給拉進來
把主權基金
把一般民眾給拉進來
很快的我們在理專推薦的產品當中
你可能買到一個產品
他跟你說
這個可能是田納西州
某兩顆Blackwell GPU的晶片
你也算是參與AI行情了
就是一代一代的往下傳
然後這一代一代
一層貸款一層貸款的
往外擴一直影響到民間市場
這就是我們觀察到的事實跡象
博通的模式是更加值得注意的
銀行團目前準備為
Enthropy和AI相關公司
要籌措大概600億美元的晶片融資
其中有420億美元
就屬於優先擔保融資
另外有180億美元屬於順位融資
黑石現在針對整個博通的模式
大概又為他增長了350億美元
他主要就是協助Entropy
去購買博通製造的晶片
那博通呢
透過部分高順位的債券
再提供更進一步的信用支撐
反正就是現在去賣晶片的人
都要先幫自己的客戶籌錢就對了
回答要賣晶片
就先幫自己的雲端客戶籌錢
或者掛保證
那博通要賣晶片
他也先用高順位的債券
來提供信用支撐
我先確保我的客戶不會倒
我再叫他多買一點我的晶片
差不多都是這樣的一個感覺
所以不斷的向下來進行投放以後
這就是一個新的融資環境
當然這也說明著
有人認為這是利多
有人認為這是利空
你一年看到亞馬遜瘋狂的做投入
第一個可能反映是
需求強到連科技巨頭
自己的現金流都不夠了
那肯定是AI剛開始
他們多看好AI
他們願意即便要花這麼龐大的
高的殖利率
瘋狂的借錢
即便利率成本已經那麼昂貴
他們還是要借下去
他們多看好AI
這利多角度
那另外一個角度就是流動性
那看起來還可以玩一陣子
但是往反方向想
大家當然會覺得
這表外承諾越來越高
一個季度就成長一點巴掌
市場哪來這麼多錢
在多頭眼中
這不是泡沫
這是動員整個資本市場往前推
但對於相對比較保守的人
都認為
整個系統性風險只是越擴越大
如果AI最後無法造成生產力提升
那最後只是一場空
而且是所有這些頂尖的企業
不管好的壞的
頂尖的市佔率大的
你都已經參與這場遊戲
甚至連主權基金
退休基金
未來都參與這場遊戲
大家就一起死
這個是多空不同角度的看法
但是最後還是取決於你
到底你是用什麼樣的一個角度
來做思維
同樣一組數據
你到了空頭眼裡
它就是另外一個世界
售後租回
私人信貸表外融資
每一個看起來都像是08年
但對多頭來看
它就是需求的證明
它就是市場上需要更多的資金
來推動本輪的生產鏈
所以最後還是完全取決於
那你到底看到了什麼
每個人看到的畫面
或者原本既有的立場
會影響到未來一系列
你是否參與本輪的AI行情
剛才講到希特勒
之前講說二戰結束之後
各國軍人都開始
開始互相歡慶和平的到來
那有三名大兵
日本美國和德國的
就到美國人的老家
去看脫衣舞表演
脫衣舞女脫完之後
日本兵就敬禮了
脫衣女不急
你向我敬禮幹嘛呢
我看到了我日本的太陽旗
見到國旗我當然要敬禮
脫衣女就不理他
繼續跳舞
後來美國兵又對他開始敬禮
那女郎說
你對我敬禮幹嘛呢
後來一看
因為我看到了我的美國國旗
就是那個短故事
美國的新條國旗
我看到之後
我就忍不住想要敬禮了
那女郎有一點惱火
繼續跳
她跳著跳著
德國兵也向她敬禮了
那女郎不急
你為什麼也要向我敬禮
德國兵說
我看到了我們元首的鬍子
所以同樣一組數字
你在不同人的眼裡
你看到的是完全另外一個世界
現在有些人看到的是需求的證明
看到的是融資的需求
看到的是AI的爆發
很多人看到的是槓桿的警訊
所以有時候我們要這樣想
一個投資人
你看什麼像什麼
真正困難的
不是說你找到一個
支持自己觀點的數據
因為市場上永遠都找得到
相關的數據來支撐你
而是你究竟看到的是事實本身
還是你已經先看多先看空了
所以你才找一個數據
來推演你或者推進你的思想
我們當然有自己的立場
必須承認
可是它有內生性的影響
就是人類幾百年來
歷史的週期就是這樣子
科技本身是不會有泡沫的
泡沫都是資產化的一個吹捧
但是從目前來看
資產化的吹捧
它是否導致了本益比的全面失真
融資遊戲是有點危險的
可是有沒有發現
每隔幾個月
市場就會自己嚇自己
利率這麼高了
估值要削減一下
AI永動機
去年10月份不可能因為玩下去的
必須要適度回答一下
如果市場隨時都存在
這種校正迴歸
隨時都存在
這種情緒上的反覆
那我認為
其實你說
距離到全面樂觀
市場的全面失控
似乎就並不是如此
想象中來的
如此之樂觀了
這是我的看法
其實從大型股
跟小型股的分化
獲利好跟獲利不好的
有AI的指數
跟沒AI的指數
當中的分化
你大概已經看得出來了
市場上並不是
一方面全面性的
看多數我資產
而是在高利率時代
更為精挑細選的
選擇自己相信AI的生產力未來
也給投資朋友做一些參考
臺股上漲140點
摔49,853點
好臺股看起來
衝高到5萬點
基本上是勢不可擋
那重點是5萬點的下一步是什麼呢
是更多Terafair的訂單
還是藉由融資遊戲繼續玩下去呢
至少可以承認的事情是
過去光是靠內資
就足以讓臺股
從當時2萬多點
到現在4萬多點
那外資的回補
只要稍微加大一點
這個創高的速度
你說會比過去兩年
還要來得慢嗎
這就不一定了
因為外資的回補
資金量體
其實是非常龐大的
也給投資朋友做一些參考
市場的籌碼動態
是否產生了新一輪的變化
值得留意
如果喜歡我們節目
記得幫我們訂閱按贊加分享
我們就明天早上半班
早晨財經速解讀
再將見
祝各位投資朋友
開盤順利
籌盤愉快